The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: Let's
go now to storyboard 36,
starting with panel A,
Regulation of Metabolism.
So far in 5.07, we have
looked at metabolic pathways
from the perspective of the cell
in organelles within the cell.
Using physiological
scenarios, I've
tried to show you how
pathways within the cell
respond to a change in the
environment, for example,
by running away from a
stressor, such as a dog
or dealing with the problems
of starvation or diabetes.
We have looked a
little bit at the ways
that individual steps and
pathways are regulated.
We have not, however,
looked at the ways
that individual pathways
and individual organs
coordinate their respective
activities in order
to accommodate the needs
of the entire organism.
Coordinated pathway networking
is the focus of this lecture.
Let's turn to panel B.
I'm going to start out
by talking a little bit
about the seven pathways
that we have studied
in detail in 5.07
and look at how
they're regulated.
As I've said before,
typically pathways
are regulated at their
rate-determining steps, that
is, the step at which
you'll find an enzyme that
has a large free-energy
change associated
with the conversion of
substrates to products.
In the first pathway
we studied, glycolysis,
there are three irreversible
steps, specifically
the glucokinase/hexokinase
step; secondly,
the phosphofructokinase-1 step;
and thirdly, the last step,
pyruvate kinase.
These are all sites
of pathway regulation.
Our second pathway, the
tricarboxylic acid cycle,
or Krebs cycle, was regulated
at every step at which NADH
is produced, that is,
citrate dehydrogenase,
alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase,
and malate dehydrogenase.
While pyruvate dehydrogenase
is not formally
part of the TCA cycle,
I'll point out here
that it is also
regulated by NADH.
In all four cases,
NADH feedback inhibits
the enzymes that produce it.
Under conditions of
excessive TCA cycle activity,
you'll find that NADH
levels will drop,
and accordingly NAD+
levels will increase.
The reduction in
NADH will result
in activation of the pathway.
In other words, the
disappearance of NADH
results in the uninhibition
of the pathway.
Our third pathway,
gluconeogenesis,
is regulated at the
pyruvate carboxylase step
at the fructose
1,6-bisphosphatase step
and at the glycogen
synthase/glycogen phosphorylase
steps.
We're going to be looking at
this pathway in some detail
in a little while.
Our fourth pathway,
fatty acid catabolism,
is regulated at the CAT, or
Carnitine Acyltransferase step,
which is inhibited by malonyl
coenzyme A. Malonyl CoA
is one of the key precursors
for fatty acid biosynthesis.
It makes sense that
the concentration
of malonyl coenzyme
A, if high, would
inhibit the uptake
of fatty acids
into the mitochondrial matrix.
Keep in mind that uptake into
the matrix is the job of CAT1.
Shutting down CAT1 by the high
concentration of malonyl CoA
prevents entry of fatty acids
into the mitochondrial matrix,
where they otherwise would be
subjected to beta-oxidation.
By turning off CAT1,
malonyl coenzyme A
prevents the futile cycle
of simultaneous fatty acid
degradation and biosynthesis.
The fifth pathway is
fatty acid biosynthesis.
Acetyl-CoA Carboxylase,
or ACC, is the enzyme
that makes malonyl coenzyme
A out of its precursor,
acetyl coenzyme A. This enzyme,
ACC, is activated by insulin.
As we've seen before,
insulin detects the fed state
in the organism.
Hence, following a meal,
insulin levels rise,
and that's the signal that
tells the cells of the body
to take up nutrients.
That's just one example.
After a meal, glucose levels
will rise in the blood.
Insulin will be released
and drive the glucose
into the cell.
The cell will then
activate pathways
by which the glucose is
converted to acetyl-CoA.
Then the acetyl-CoA will be
converted into fatty acids,
and then ultimately,
into triacylglycerides
for energy storage.
Our sixth regulated pathway is
the pentose phosphate pathway.
Glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase
is the first step
in the pathway.
And as we often see, an
early or committed step
is where regulation happens.
One of the products of
the pentose phosphate
pathway is NADPH.
If the cell has
used a lot of NADPH,
for example for biosynthesis,
its levels will drop.
Coordinately, there will
be an increase in NADP+.
In the case of glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase,
we find that NADP+, which is the
product of excessive reductive
biosynthesis, as well
as other activities,
such as combating
oxidative stress,
activates the dehydrogenase in
order to enable the synthesis
of additional NADPH in order
to sustain biosynthesis.
The last pathway, the
seventh, is electron transport
and oxidative phosphorylation.
This is our most robust pathway
for the production of ATP.
When there's a lot
of demand for ATP,
ADP levels will
rise in the cell.
And it's ultimately
the level of ADP
that regulates
electron transport
in oxidative phosphorylation.
More about that
in a few minutes.
Let's now look at panel
C. Organs communicate
with one another by the
nervous system, of course,
but also by hormones,
small molecules that
are secreted by
one organ that will
have an effect at
one or more organs
distal to the first organ.
Changes in our
environment are detected
by the brain with input
from our sensory organs.
Our internal organs, such as
the liver, pancreas, kidneys,
adrenal glands, and muscles
will detect signals,
either independently of the
brain or after an instruction
set is received from the brain.
The resulting signal network
will allow the entire organism
to be able to adapt to
the new environment,
be it one of stress, for
example, being chased by a dog,
or one of, for example, hunger.
We'll talk later about
the adrenal glands, which
are going to respond
to signals that
come in from sensory organs
that tell our muscles to start
running and to tell the
liver to start to provide
the muscles with the
glucose they need in order
to sustain running.
Later we'll be
looking in some detail
at the adrenal-produced hormone
epinephrine, also called
adrenaline.
Adrenaline will have a profound
impact, both in the muscles
and in the liver, to
allow these organs
to do their respective jobs.
The pancreas is a
very important organ
in that it provides
exocrine functions that
help with digestion
and endocrine
functions that enable us
to regulate or balance
fuel metabolism.
The alpha cells of the
pancreas produce glucagon.
The alpha cells sense hunger.
They secrete glucagon
into the blood,
which travels to organs that
represent our fuel depots.
And fuel from those depots,
for example, fatty acids
and glucose, will
then be supplied
to other tissues of the body
that are in need of nutrition.
The beta cells of
the pancreas sense
what we call the fed state,
and they produce insulin.
Insulin instructs
the various organs
of the body to take up
fuel in the wake of us
having eaten a meal.
Now let's look at
panel D. There are
three general paradigms by
which pathways are regulated.
The three hormones that I've
just mentioned typically
will cause the activation of a
kinase that will phosphorylate
a target protein, resulting in
either increased or decreased
activity of that protein.
We call this hormonal or, more
properly, covalent control,
because there will be a covalent
modification of a protein that
will be responsible
for pathway regulation.
The second major paradigm by
which pathways are controlled
is allosteric regulation.
Earlier in 5.07,
JoAnne Stubbe showed us
how hemoglobin,
the molecule that
carries oxygen in the
blood, is controlled
by bisphosphoglycerate
and protons, which
act as allosteric effectors.
Similarly, other small
molecule effectors
will control the major
pathways of metabolism.
We're going to be looking
at phosphofructokinase-1
as our prime example.
The third strategy
of regulation is
what I call "acceptor control."
This is the way that electron
transport and oxidative
phosphorylation are regulated.
To the right side of panel D
is an abbreviated metabolic
pathway that I'm going to use
to describe each of these three
paradigms.
At the upper left is
a box that contains
glycogen synthase and
glycogen phosphorylase.
Earlier in 5.07, I told
you how phosphorylation
of a specific C-ring
residue on glycogen
phosphorylase results
in a dramatic increase
in the activity of that enzyme.
A little later, we'll see that
covalent modification, again,
by serine phosphorylation of
glycogen synthase, results
in a decrease in
activity of that enzyme.
Hence, covalent modification
of these two proteins
enables, in one case,
activation of the enzyme
and, in the other case,
inhibition of the enzyme.
This reciprocal control
prevents futile cycling.
Now let's look at
the box in the center
of this abbreviated
metabolic pathway.
The glycolytic enzyme,
PFK-1, Phosphofructokinase-1,
converts fructose 6-phosphate
to fructose 1,6-bisphosphate.
We're going to see that a small
molecule derivative of fructose
6-phosphate, specifically
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate,
will act as a powerful
allosteric stimulator of PFK-1.
I'll also point out that
AMP, Adenosine Monophosphate,
will also stimulate this enzyme.
I'll also point out here
that PFK-1 is a tetramer.
Oftentimes, as JoAnne taught
us, proteins that are multimers
are the ones that are subject
to allosteric regulation.
Our third paradigm of
regulation is accepter control,
shown in the box at
the bottom of panel D.
During periods of intense
physical activity,
ATP is consumed and
converted to ADP,
and NADH is converted to NAD+.
Rising levels of ADP in
the mitochondrial matrix
activate the
proton-translocating ATP
synathase.
As more protons flow through
the synthase, more ATP is made.
They call this accepter control,
because the regulatory molecule
is ADP, which is the,
quote unquote, "acceptor
of phosphate" in the
synthesis of ATP.
Because we covered
accepter control
in some detail in the
lecture on electron transport
and oxidative
phosphorylation, I'm
going to leave
that topic for now
and focus on covalent control
and allosteric control.
Let's turn now to
storyboard 37, starting
with panel A. With regard to the
paradigm of covalent control,
I'm going to focus on the
pair of enzymes, glycogen
synthase and glycogen
phosphorylase,
which reciprocally
regulate glycogen synthesis
and glycogenolysis.
Let's consider a
scenario in which
there's some kind of stressor.
The muscles have to
be activated in order
to be able to deal
with the stress,
and the liver has to be able
to provide the resources
to the muscles that will
allow the muscles to continue
intense physical activity.
Now let's look at panel
B. In our scenario,
you've just seen
something frightening.
Your brain then sends
an electrical signal
to the adrenal
glands, which then
send a chemical signal,
specifically adrenaline,
to the liver and to the muscles.
At the top part of
this response scenario,
both the liver and
muscles are going
to be responding in
a very similar way.
However, at the bottom part
of the response scenario,
the liver and muscles are
going to be activating
very different pathways.
Specifically, we're going to
see that muscles will strongly
activate glycolytic
pathways in order
to enable the production of ATP
to keep the muscles running.
The liver, by contrast, is going
to be activating pathways that
are more like those of
gluconeogenesis, that is,
spilling out fuel from
the liver to provide
the muscles with the
energy-rich resources
that it needs to keep us
running away from our stressor.
Adrenaline, or epinephrine,
travels from the adrenal
glands through the blood.
It takes only a second or
two for this to happen.
It's received by the
liver and the muscles
at the beta-adrenergic receptor.
The blood concentration of
epinephrine is very low,
something of the order
of 10 to the minus 10
molar at this point.
There's going to be a
very substantial signal
amplification as we move ahead.
Keep in mind for later
that the initial triggering
signal is in the 10 to
the minus 10 molar range.
The arrival of epinephrine
at the receptor
results in structural changes
in the transmembrane domain
of the beta-adrenergic receptor.
The signal is received
by a heterotrimeric G
protein, shown as the circle
with alpha, beta, and gamma
subunits.
This G protein, in
its inactive state,
has a bound molecule of GDP,
that is, guanosine diphosphate.
Upon receipt of the signal from
the beta-adrenergic receptor,
the heterotrimeric G protein
ejects the beta and gamma
subunits, and the GDP molecule,
which is non-covalently bound,
is released.
The GDP is replaced by a
GTP, guanosine triphosphate.
This replacement
results in the formation
of the alpha subunit with
a non-covalently bound GTP.
This is the active
form of the enzyme.
It translocates along the
inner surface of the membrane
until it encounters
AC, or adenyl cyclase.
The GTP-bound G protein
activates adenyl cyclase.
The activated AC
dynamically starts
converting ATP, which is
very abundant in the cell,
into cyclic AMP.
We call cyclic AMP
the second messenger.
In our scenario,
the first messenger
is epinephrine,
which interacted with
the beta-adrenergic receptor.
The second messenger
is cyclic AMP,
which is produced by the
activation of adenyl cyclase,
which is asymmetrically
associated
with the inner surface
of the cell's membrane.
Let's turn now to panel C.
In the upper left of panel C,
you'll see a box.
This box depicts the
chemical mechanism
leading to the
production of cyclic AMP.
Let's now look at the
main part of the panel.
In a very short period
of time, a matter
of seconds, the concentration
of cyclic AMP within the cell
goes from about 1 micromolar
up to about 5 micromolar.
So the presence of epinephrine
at the 10 to the minus 10
molar concentration
outside the cell
results in a perturbation
of cyclic AMP concentrations
inside the cell, bringing cyclic
AMP concentration to about 10
to the minus 6 molar.
This is a very
substantial increase
in signal, which an
engineer would call gain.
The increasing cyclic
AMP concentration
is going to activate
a kinase cascade.
And the initial kinase
that's going to be activated
is called Protein
Kinase A, or PKA,
which is represented
symbolically as a C
with a circle around
it in my drawing.
In its inactive state,
protein kinase A
is in a complex involving
two molecules of itself
and two molecules of a
regulatory protein, which
I've indicated as an R in
the middle of a circle.
Cyclic AMP forms a
tight complex with R.
This basically causes
R to dissociate
from the active
subunit C, that is,
the catalytic portion
of protein kinase
A. The catalytic portion
of protein kinase A
is now free to act as a
kinase to phosphorylate
the next kinase in
the cascade, which
is called SPK, or Synthase
Phosphorylase Kinase.
A serine residue on
SPK is phosphorylated,
and that event converts this
kinase into its active form.
I'll also point out that
one of the subunits,
the delta subunit of SPK, is
the calcium-binding protein
calmodulin, which gives a
second level of regulation
to this enzyme.
Specifically, this
enzyme is regulated
not only by the
concentration of cyclic AMP,
but also by the levels of
calcium within the cell.
The activated SPK, or
synthase phosphorylase kinase,
is now going to phosphorylate
two other proteins, glycogen
phosphorylase and
glycogen synthase.
As I mentioned earlier,
phosphorylation of glycogen
phosphorylase results in the
enzyme becoming more active.
That is, it starts breaking
down glycogen by phosphorolysis
to produce glucose
1-phosphate, which
will then be available for
further metabolic processing.
In the muscle,
glucose 1-phosphate
will be converted by
phosphoglucomutase
into glucose 6-phosphate,
which will then be a substrate
to initiate glycolysis, with
the ultimate generation of lots
of ATP for the muscle.
In the liver,
phosphoglucomutase will
convert glucose 1-phosphate
into glucose 6-phosphate,
but in this case,
gluconeogenesis
will be activated.
Glucose 6-phosphatase
will remove the phosphate
from glucose 6-phosphate,
converting it to glucose.
The glucose will then be
secreted from the liver,
go out into the
blood, and then go
to the muscle to help the
muscle carry out glycolysis.
Now let's look at the
other target of SPK,
synthase phosphorylase
kinase, specifically,
glycogen synthase.
In this case, glycogen synthase
phosphorylation results
in a less active protein,
and hence, glycogen synthesis
will cease.
This makes sense, because
a cell under stress
would not want to be making
glycogen. It wants to be using
energy and not storing fuel.
Let's step back and look at
the big picture at this point.
The interaction of
a hormone resulted
in the covalent
modification of proteins.
One of those
phosphorylated proteins,
glycogen phosphorylase,
triggered glycogen breakdown.
Phosphorylation of a second
protein, glycogen synthase,
turned it off.
Turning off glycogen
synthase helped
us avoid the otherwise
futile simultaneous synthesis
and breakdown of glycogen.
So overall, this is an
example of a hormone causing
covalent modification of
proteins in such a way
that it altered the
activity of those proteins
in a manner that
made sense given
the physiological
challenges to the organism.
Next, let's turn
to storyboard 38,
panel A. Our next
regulatory paradigm
will be the use of
allosteric effectors
to regulate a pathway.
As before, I'm going to use
the physiological scenario
of stress.
But in this case,
I'm going to show
how stress will
cause the production
of small-molecule
allosteric effectors
that will activate
glycolysis in the muscle
and activate gluconeogenesis
in the liver.
Our focal point is going to be
PFK-1, phosphofructokinase-1,
of glycolysis.
Of central importance is
going to be a small molecule,
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate, which
we'll see is going to be a very
powerful allosteric
stimulant of PFK-1.
Fructose 2,6-bisphosphate
is made by the enzyme PFK-2,
phosphofructokinase-2.
Let's start out by
looking at the very
short biochemical pathway shown
in panel A. We see glucose
converted by hexokinase
or glucokinase
to glucose 6-phosphate
and then some equilibrium
steps up until we get
fructose 6-phosphate.
Ordinarily, we think
of fructose 6-phosphate
as continuing in the
glycolytic pathway,
but let's not think of
it that way right now.
The chemical structure
of fructose 6-phosphate
is shown slightly to the right.
Note that fructose
6-phosphate has
a phosphate on the
6-hydroxyl group,
and that the 1-hydroxyl
functionality
has only a hydrogen.
This is the alpha
anomer of fructose,
as evidenced by the fact that
the hydroxyl group on carbon-2,
the anomeric position, is down,
or under the furanose ring.
With a little bit
of electron pushing,
you can change the
stereochemistry
at the 2-carbon such that the
hydroxyl group would be up,
or in the beta configuration.
In the beta configuration,
the hydroxymethyl group
of fructose 6-phosphate,
which includes its 1-carbon,
would be down.
The beta and alpha-anomers
of fructose 6-phosphate
are in equilibrium.
That is, they both
exist at the same time.
The kinase,
phosphofructokinase-2,
catches the beta anomer
of fructose 6-phosphate
and phosphorylates it, producing
the molecule at the lower
right of this panel.
That's the actual structure
of fructose 2,6-bisphosphate.
This is the molecule
that's going
to serve as the
allosteric effector
of the glycolysis pathway.
The PFK-2, or
phosphofructokinase-2 enzyme,
is shown to the left.
It's a complex
enzyme having lots
of different functionalities.
The hatched circle within
the larger circle at the top
represents the
phosphofructokinase domain,
which converts fructose
6-phosphate to fructose
2,6-bisphosphate.
That is the structure
at the lower right.
The hatched domain at the bottom
is the fructose bisphosphatase
domain.
This is an unusual enzyme.
In the top domain, it acts as
a kinase, in the bottom domain,
acts as a phosphatase.
PFK-2 has two
hydroxylated amino acids,
one at about 3 o'clock as
drawn and the other at about 6
o'clock.
When the hydroxyl
group at the bottom
is present as a pure,
unmodified hydroxyl group,
the protein acts as a kinase.
When the 6 o'clock
domain is phosphorylated,
the enzyme acts
as a phosphatase.
Protein kinase A, or PKA,
from the previous storyboard,
where we talked about
hormonal regulation,
is the kinase that
phosphorylates
the hydroxyl group at 6
o'clock on the protein.
As we'll see later, the
hydroxyl group at 3 o'clock
is targeted by a kinase called
AMP kinase in the muscle.
Before we go on, I want you to
look carefully at the structure
of fructose 2,6-bisphosphate
at the bottom right of panel A.
Compare that structure with
the structure of fructose
1,6-bisphosphate at
the right in panel B.
If you squint and look
at these two molecules,
you'll see that they
look remarkably alike.
In both cases, the
phosphate group
is above the plane of
the furanose sugar.
However, in the case of
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate,
the phosphate is
on the 2-carbon,
whereas with fructose
1,6-bisphosphate,
the phosphate is
on the 1-carbon.
The way these molecules
look will become important
in a few minutes.
Now let's take a
look at the pathway
as shown in panel
B. Panel B reflects
the liver in its normal,
that is, non-stress state.
So this is just the liver
doing everyday liver business.
Glucokinase of the liver
is converting glucose
to glucose 6-phosphate.
The alpha anomer of fructose
6-phosphate is produced.
Most of the fructose 6-phosphate
is converted to fructose
1,6-bisphosphate.
In the liver cell at
this time, there's
probably some low level of
glycolytic activity going on.
However, because of
natural anomerization,
some of the
alpha-fructose 6-phosphate
is converted to its beta-anomer.
Phosphofructokinase-2, or PFK-2,
is shown to the lower left,
and it's active.
Note that neither of its
hydroxyl groups, at this point,
are phosphorylated.
And its kinase site will be
converting the beta-fructose
6-phosphate anomer to its
phosphorylated form, that is,
beta-fructose 2,6-bisphosphate,
which has the structure shown
at the bottom right
of the previous panel.
Fructose 2,6-bisphosphate is
a positive allosteric effector
of phosphofructokinase-1.
So it facilitates the
glycolytic pathway
that is enabling net flux from
left to right in the pathway
as shown.
In addition to
stimulating glycolysis,
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate
strongly inhibits
gluconeogenesis.
It does this by binding at
the active site of fructose
1,6-bisphosphatase, the
gluconeogenic enzyme,
clogging up the active
site, and thus disabling
the gluconeogenic pathway.
The reason that it's such a good
inhibitor of gluconeogenesis
stems from an
examination, once again,
of the structures of fructose
2,6-bisphosphate in the bottom
right of the previous panel and
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate shown
to the right on this panel.
Keep in mind that
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate,
while it's the
product in glycolysis,
is the substrate for the
gluconeogenic reaction.
If the active site of the
fructose 1,6-bisphosphatase is
clogged by fructose
2,6-bisphosphate,
then it's not going to be
able to process the fructose
1,6-bisphosphate in the
gluconeogenic direction.
Hence, gluconeogenesis
is strongly inhibited.
All of the above shows us that
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate is
really important.
It stimulates the
forward direction
in the liver that is
causing glycolysis to have
a net flux from left to right.
And in addition, it strongly
inhibits the back reaction,
that is, the reaction in
the gluconeogenic direction.
Turn at this point to panel C.
Now let's ramp up the scenario
and think about a
situation in which you're
being chased by a dog.
You want to be able to
generate glucose in the liver
and then export that
glucose to the muscles
so that you can run
away from your foe.
This is a situation in which you
would like to have your liver
stop doing glycolysis.
You want the liver to strongly
turn to gluconeogenesis
in order to manufacture
glucose for the muscle.
At this point, refer
back to the storyboard
that dealt with covalent
control, where protein kinase
A was activated.
Recall the part of
the lecture when
I talked about covalent
control, and we
were talking about the
glycogen phosphorylase
step in the liver.
In the liver, we generated
first glucose 1-phosphate
and then glucose 6-phosphate.
And then the phosphate
was lopped off the glucose
6-phosphate to produce glucose
that went out into the blood.
In the present
case, we're looking
at a step that's further down
in the gluconeogenesis pathway.
Specifically, we want
to activate the fructose
1,6-bisphosphatase in order
to push even more carbohydrate
toward the production
of glucose.
So in panel C, we see stress
inducing the cyclic AMP cascade
that results in activation of
protein kinase A. And protein
kinase A is going
to phosphorylate
the southernmost, that is, 6
o'clock domain, on the PFK-2,
or phosphofructokinase-2
protein.
As I indicated earlier,
phosphorylation
of the 6 o'clock domain
results in conversion
of phosphofructokinase-2 from
a kinase into a phosphatase.
The phosphatase produced from
PFK-2 will act upon the pool
of fructose 2,6-bisphosphate and
convert that pool to fructose
6-phosphate.
That is, the 2-phosphate will
be lopped off of the fructose
2,6-bisphosphate molecule.
By doing this
biochemistry in the liver,
we've done two things.
First, we destroyed the
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate pool.
Hence, this molecule
is no longer
available to act as an
allosteric stimulator of PFK-1.
Secondly, removing fructose
2,6-bisphosphate from the pool
has resulted in removal of
the active-site inhibitor
of fructose 1,6-bisphosphatase.
This enzyme, therefore,
becomes active
and is able to push
the net flux of carbon
from right to left in the
direction of gluconeogenesis,
producing glucose that will
then spill out into the blood.
Please turn now to
panel D. We just
saw that the liver,
post-stress, produces glucose.
Now we're going to take a
look at the muscle, which,
of course, is going to
be using that glucose.
In response to the
stress state, the muscle
is going to activate
an enzyme called
the AMP-dependent
protein kinase,
or AMP kinase,
also known as AMPK.
AMPK activates metabolic
pathways that generate ATP.
The 3 o'clock phosphorylated
PFK-2 proves to be
an exceptionally competent
enzyme for converting fructose
6-phosphate into fructose
2,6-bisphosphate.
This increases further the
concentration of fructose
2,6-bisphosphate in the
muscle cytoplasmic pool.
And keep in mind that fructose
2,6-bisphosphate itself is
a powerful allosteric stimulator
of glycolysis by its effect
on PFK-1.
So in the muscle cell, we're
able to achieve extraordinarily
high concentrations of
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate,
thus favoring glycolysis.
Let's turn now to storyboard 39.
Let's start with
panel A. The way
that AMP kinase stimulates
glycolysis in the muscle
post-stress is illustrated
in this abbreviated metabolic
pathway.
Starting at the lower
left, the stressor
has created the
cyclic AMP cascade
that activates AMP kinase.
AMP kinase phosphorylates the
3 o'clock domain on PFK-2,
converting it to its
phosphorylated derivative that
shows powerful kinase activity
to convert fructose 6-phosphate
into fructose 2,6-bisphosphate.
This enhanced pool of fructose
2,6-bisphosphate will now act
as a powerful allosteric
stimulator of PFK-1 to favor
glycolysis.
I want to point out that muscles
do not do gluconeogenesis.
Only the liver and renal
cortex do this pathway.
So muscles do not have
fructose 1,6-bisphosphatase,
the gluconeogenic enzyme.
Accordingly, in
muscles we don't have
to worry about gluconeogenesis
being turned on to some extent
and thus dampening
the glycolytic effect
in the muscle that's needed
in order for the muscle
to generate the ATP
needed to outrun your foe.
On this panel, we
also see that there
are several other
effectors that influence
the activity of PFK-1.
One is citrate.
Another is ATP.
Another one is AMP, or
Adenosine Monophosphate.
I want to say a couple of
words about AMP in this regard.
Let's look at panel B. AMP is
not as powerful an allosteric
effector on PFK-1 as is
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate.
But we know a lot
about its activity
as an allosteric
effector because it's
been studied quite thoroughly.
PFK-1 is a tetramer,
and its activity
is regulated by cooperativity.
This graph shows the
activity of PFK-1
as a function of the
concentration of one
of its substrates,
fructose 6-phosphate.
When there's no
ATP present, which
is not a realistic
situation, you
see the regulatory
pattern following that
of a rectangular hyperbola.
That's scenario A.
Scenario B shows
what would happen
to the activity
of the enzyme when
ATP is present at a
concentration of about
1 millimolar, which
is quite realistic,
and what you see is
suppressed activity.
When the heterotropic allosteric
effector AMP is added,
you see the curve
shift to the left.
That is, you get enhanced
activity at a given substrate
concentration.
My guess is that fructose
2,6-bisphosphate would push
the curve even
further to the left.
Let's now look at panel C. I
think it's useful to use AMP
to help us construct a model for
what fructose 2,6-bisphosphate
might be doing as an allosteric
stimulator of the PFK-1 enzyme.
The equilibrium
diagram that I've drawn
shows the relationship
between the relaxed, that
is, more active state
of the PFK-1 tetramer,
and the tense, that is, more
inactive state of the enzyme.
When ATP is abundant
within a cell,
it binds more strongly
to the tense state,
and hence, ATP
inactivates PFK-1.
This makes sense, because
if ATP is abundant,
you do not want to
be doing glycolysis
to make even more ATP.
However, when the
ATP pool of a cell
is challenged by doing
heavy work or biosynthesis,
the AMP is going to
bind more tightly
to the R state of PFK-1.
And that's going to
help convert the enzyme
into its more active state.
That's a little snapshot of how
a small molecule, in this case,
AMP or perhaps fructose
2,6-bisphosphate can
dramatically regulate
the activity of an enzyme
at a specific step
in metabolism.